[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
entretien de France 24 avec nous
aujourd'hui le porte-parole du chef des
thèmes majeur des armées françaises le
général Pascal Yanni mon Général bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
l'invitation de France 24 en cette
période troublée on cite on sait que les
armées sont soumises à de fortes
pressions je pense bien évidemment à la
guerre en Ukraine mais en ce qui
concerne l'armée française la vôtre il y
a aussi cette fin d'air cette fin
d'histoire cette page qu'on tourne au
Mali puisque dans quelques temps les
derniers soldats français vont quitter
Gao la base de Gao dans le nord du du
Mali mettant fin à un engagement qui
avait commencé en 2013 avec l'opération
Serval puis l'opération barkhane 5000
hommes et femmes engagées à pied
d'oeuvre sur le terrain alors en général
première question est-ce que c'est un
acte de décès de cette opération
barkhane alors comme vous l'avez comme
vous l'avez signalé il s'agit d'une page
qui va se tourner effectivement avec le
transfert de Gao qui est prévu pour pour
la fin de pour la fin du mois d'août
transfert de la base de Gao qui est la
dernière base française au Mali qui est
la plus grande base française en Afrique
de l'Ouest plus de plus de 2000 hommes
qui sont stationnés ça marquera
effectivement la fin la présence
française au Mali mais c'était pas du
tout la fin de l'histoire de la lutte
contre les groupes armées terroristes
puisque les armées françaises vont
rester engagés de manière significative
aux côtés des des armées sahéliennes à
leur demande je pense en particulier au
Niger au Tchad pour combattre ces
groupes armées terroristes nous allons
continuer nos actions de coopération et
de partenariat militaires opérationnels
avec les pays du Golf de Guinée nous
sommes présents en Côte d'Ivoire nous
avons une coopération ancienne avec le
Bénin avec le Togo nous sommes présents
également au Sénégal donc c'est une page
qui tourne mais l'histoire continue
parce que la menace terroriste reste
plaignante elle reste réelle il y a un
vrai risque de dispersion vers le Gold
le Gold de Guinée et l'idée c'est bien
de de répondre aux besoins exprimés par
les pays de la région au premier rang
desquels les pays Saliens et d'y
répondre à la fois du côté français mais
aussi
de quitter le Mali et d'ailleurs nous
quittons le Mali en bon ordre en
sécurité au rythme que nous avons décidé
nous allons les choses correctement nous
les faisons de manière très sereine de
manière très posée et ce que nous
voulons simplement c'est que cette
réarticulation hors du malice se passe
dans de très bonnes conditions parce que
le combat continue ailleurs sur la
question de la sécurité au Mali où on en
est où sécuritément puisque bon les
Français il est acté qui vont partir on
sait qu'aujourd'hui il y a des Bizzbee
c'est le moins de qu'on puisse dire avec
le nu avec la force de maintien de la
paix la minusma de gros problèmes
opérationnels et techniques sur le sur
le terrain où est-ce qu'on en est
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire de la sécurité
notamment dans le normalis que les
Français vont quitter alors
effectivement l'armée française quitte
la zone des trois frontières et quitte
la zone de Gao ce que je peux vous dire
avant c'est que nous avions obtenu de
très bons résultats contre l'État
islamique au Grand Sahara notamment
depuis janvier 2020 à la fois dans le
liptaquon Nigérien dans la dans le livre
tacomania vous savez dans cette zone
qu'on appelle la zone des trois
frontières entre le Mali le Niger le
Burkina on a neutralisé le chef de de
l'IGS en août 2021 on avait vraiment mis
le IGS sous pression le GS était
incapable de mener les attaques
d'envergure ce qu'on constate
aujourd'hui c'est que du fait de la
suspension des opérations conjointes à
la suite des décisions qui ont été
prises par les autorités maliennes et
notamment le recours à la SMV Wagner on
voit le geste qui remonte en puissance
il y a un vrai sujet sur la remontée en
puissance en particulier au Mali de
l'État islamique au grand Sart dans la
zone des trois frontières et ce qu'on
avait réussi à empêcher c'était la
territorialisation la création d'un
califat territorial par l'EGS et ça
c'est une question qui va rester pendant
maintenant puisque on ne sait pas
jusqu'où le US va pouvoir remonter en
puissance mais le rêve fantasmé de la
création de ce calife islamique au Sahel
c'est une possibilité avec le retrait de
la France du Mali alors c'est ce qui est
ce qui semble possible et je suis pas un
devin mais ce qui semble possible c'est
que le js réussit à prendre le contrôle
d'une zone au Mali et puis s'en faire
une une sorte de base arrière une base à
partir desquels elle pourra
l'organisation interagir ailleurs au
Mali voir ailleurs dans la sous-région
ça c'est une possibilité c'est un
scénario possible mais je ne suis pas un
devin sur la question encore pour tenter
d'un peu de faire un bilan de cette
opération barkhane qui a mobilisé c'est
le plus grand engagement en français à
l'extérieur en 2013 l'opération sera
français en l'occurrence la Légion a été
accueilli en héros les sauveteurs du
Mali les sauveurs du Mali près de 9 ans
plus tard c'est vraiment la catastrophe
de de grandes tensions
rétrospectives en général comment en
étant arrivé là alors en fait cette
question est intéressante ça pose ça
pose un peu la ça pose de nombreuses
questions et nous nous l'avons nous
l'avons analysé de la façon suivante
hein les objectifs militaires ont été
ont été atteints tout ce qui a été
demandé aux armées a été fait de on l'a
toujours dit on l'a vu en Irak et en
Afghanistan et on le voit aujourd'hui
Ussel vaincre le terrorisme n'est pas
simplement une question de sécurité et
d'engagement armé c'est aussi une
question politique économique sociale
culturelle la résolution de tension
entre communautés 3 la clé de du succès
à la partie aux forces locales ce sont
les forces locales qui sont les plus
légitimes pour venir à bout des groupes
armées terroristes et contrôler leur
territoire et protéger leur population
et c'est pour cette raison que
l'opération barkhane à partir de 2014
2015 a fait effort sur la montée en
puissance des forces locales pour pour
leur permettre à terme de de d'assurer
leur mission réelle maillot là qui n'a
pas suivi en général et en fait on a on
avait bien commencé 7000 hommes l'armée
malienne 7000 hommes en 2013 40 000
aujourd'hui à peu près avec des unités
constituées la taxe la taxe takuba qui
obtient de bons résultats dans la zone
des trois frontières avec les ulries
Maliennes pareil l'armée nigérienne qui
fonctionne de mieux en mieux qui obtient
de très bons résultats sur le terrain
mais tout ça ça demande du temps de la
persévérance et une forme de de sérieux
il faut pas changer de stratégie trop
vite et tout le temps et donc le
problème aujourd'hui au Mali c'est les
ce sont les choix qui ont été faits par
les autorités maliennes et qui ont
abouti à la fin de la présence française
au Mali et qui risque de se traduire
aussi par des difficultés avec les
organisations internationales je pense à
la minusma et avec la mission européenne
de formation mes présidents pour revenir
sur ma question si vous le permettez
pourquoi ces choix et pourquoi ce
sentiment anti-français dans les rues de
Bamako mais aussi au Burkina Faso on
voit bien que ça fait tâche d'huile
encore une fois comment a pu on a pu en
arriver là alors on peut évidemment
incriminer Wagner on va en parler
évidemment mais quel bilan vous ont vous
en tirer il y a eu des erreurs quelque
part notamment en communication
qu'est-ce qui a été raté dans cette
opération en fait je ce qu'on comprend
maintenant c'est que toute une partie
d'un succès militaire
ce gagne dans le champ des perceptions
la façon dont la présence française est
perçue la façon dont les opérations sont
perçues par la population par la
population par les populations locales
et ça aujourd'hui c'est devenu un enjeu
majeur effectivement il y a un sentiment
anti-français qui s'est développé il ne
faut pas le nier il faut quand même
savoir raison garder parce qu'on a les
fait loop des réseaux sociaux il faut
pas se fier sur Twitter quand les forces
françaises opère au Mali ou quand elles
opèrent au Niger elles ne font elles ne
font face à aucun signe de défiance il
n'y a pas d'attaque il n'y a rien c'est
quand même des mouvements qui sont très
circonscrits et qui sont
instrumentalisés soit par des groupes
russes prorus proche de Wagner ou pas
soit par des mouvements panafricanistes
et donc c'est contre ces comptes ces
narratifs qui qui font porter à la
France des responsabilités qui ne sont
pas les siennes et surtout aux armées
françaises des responsabilités qui ne
sont pas les les leurs qu'il faut qu'il
faut que nous fassions un effort de
communication et cet effort de
communication on le fait dans un souci
de transparence et en le faisant
rapidement parce que l'un des
enseignements vous savez de l'attaque
informationnelle de Gossip ou la SMP
Wagner a tenté de faire accuser la
France d'avoir commis un crime de guerre
c'est que nous avons réussi à déjouer
cette attaque en montrant en
déclassifiant des images de drone en
montrant la réalité des faits et nous
l'avons fait très vite pour éviter que
ce narratif anti-français s'installe
dans le dans le champ numérique et
justement est-ce que on a les des armes
parce que l'armée française elle est
même armes que que Wagner très très
brièvement dans le champ informationnel
clairement non pourquoi parce que nos
adversaires se permettent des choses et
on fait face à une forme d'asymétrie
vous êtes versaires se permettent des
choses que nous que nous ne pouvons pas
imaginer faire ce serait contraire à nos
valeurs maquiller un crime de guerre
comme ça a été le cas Gossip crée un
faux charnier c'est quelque chose qui
est totalement inimaginable pour pour
l'armée française on efface une forme
d'asymétrie mais c'est pour autant on
est bien décidé à lutter dans le champ
informationnel contre cette
manipulations de l'information contre
ces attaques incessantes contre la
France contre les armées françaises et
contre les les armées européennes pour
montrer la vérité des choses et pour ne
pas laisser tous ces contre narratifs
tous ces toutes ces manipulations de
l'information s'installer dans les dans
l'espace informatique très rapidement
aussi le scénario malien au Burkina Faso
où on espère que non mais au Niger c'est
quelque chose de possible en tout cas le
Burkina Faso alors c'est difficile pour
moi de répondre à cette question parce
que d'abord c'est une question politique
et je ne réponds pas au sujet politique
mais d'un point de vue militaire et dans
le champ informationnel c'est quelque
chose qui est qui est envisageable mais
je pense qu'on le verra on verra les
choses apparaître on voit on voit bien
la manœuvre qui est à l'oeuvre on l'a vu
en Centrafrique avec Wagner avec la
Russie on l'a vu au Mali et on verra les
prémices arriver en l'état également le
Burkina Faso si c'est les mêmes
conditions pas du tout ce que je suis en
train de vous dire ce que je suis en
train de vous dire c'est que s'il y a
une manœuvre informationnelle contre la
France je pense qu'on sera en mesure de
la détecter et donc de tout faire pour
s'y opposer Niger rapidement aussi
meilleur allié dernier allié on se
concentre beaucoup quel est la mission
au Niger c'est un nouveau nom un nouveau
barkhane c'est quoi alors au Niger il y
a environ un millier de soldats français
articuler autour de deux grands piliers
le premier c'est la composante aérienne
à partir de la base aérienne de Niamey
avec avec des drones avec des avions de
chasse et essentiellement des missions
de renseignement des missions d'appui au
profit des forces armées nigériennes et
une deuxième composante qui est un peu
le témoin de cette stratégie qui est
mise en oeuvre depuis l'été 2021 de
partenariat militaire de combat un
groupe en tactique qui en fait évolue
dans la zone des trois frontières en
accompagnement des galets égal avec les
forces armées nigériennes pour lutter
contre les groupes armées terroristes et
ça c'est un peu le modèle de ce que nous
faisons depuis déjà de nombreux mois
mais dont on a peu parlé qui est un
partenariat pour répondre aux besoins
qui sont exprimés vers les autorités
françaises par les autorités nigériennes
général Pascal Yanni porte-paro armée
française je vous remercie c'est la fin
de cette entretien de France 24 les
programmes continuent sur nos antennes
en français en anglais en arabe et en
espagnol merci et à bientôt
[Musique]